par dix mois a vu connaît la télé je
vais te poser les questions qu'on t'a
rien qu'on a parce qu'avant elle si on a
continué une fois vérifiées ou staline
même combat alors tu vas partir de 3 ans
dans un vaisseau spatial qui me fut
mieux j'ai eu un robot c'est pire que ça
montre par là tu rêves
il ya des difficultés charmant bien
hervé vilard
elia patrick juvet en vaut mieux prendre
les trois parce que ça rentre alors
ç'a vraiment pas le choix est ce que tu
préfères faire l'amour avec une fille
très laide ou un mec très beau à la
moche ah bon tu sais si tu as fait
beaucoup les moches
oui toute manière comme son homme est
sûr d'en avoir une belle un jour un
accord oui tu préfères être réincarné en
patrick sabatier jean pierre foucault
michel drucker
mon frère s'est dit fier des questions
très con s'il s'agit de revenir sur
terre au nom vaut mieux retouches à qui
tu trouve le plus de circonstances
atténuantes à un vieux qui se tape des
petites ou un jeune qui tapent sur des
vieilles revient sur le tapis le type
avant 9 heures comment à ton avis
comment reconnaît-on les filles des
garçons alors les petites figures des
fentes et les garçons des robinets nancy
les wc pas sûr